these parabolas are going to be either
in the form x squared equals 4p y or y
squared equals 4p X okay so if you can
see that the X term is squared and the y
term is not that tells you that the
parabola is opening up or down okay
depending whether this coefficient here
the p value is positive opening up or
negative it'll be opening down now same
thing with Y squared if P is positive
it's going to open to the right if P is
negative it will open to the left now
this equation on the top here is just
where the vertex is centered at the
origin okay if it's like this bottom one
here it's been shifted okay right H and
up K so the number this group with the Y
is gonna affect the Y direction the one
this group with ax is going to affect
the X direction but opposite from the
sign so if it's like Y minus 2 that's
actually gonna go up to not down 2 so
it's the opposite if it's plus it
actually goes down if it's minus it goes
up so they're gonna have the opposite
effect on their graph so we're gonna go
through some examples will you'll
understand now what exactly is a
parabola well just to show you okay what
a parabola is it's the set of all points
okay then are equidistant so it's say
for example I drew a point right there
that are equidistant to a point called
the focus and a line called the
directrix now the way I drew my parabola
I just drew this kind of real quick but
I should have drawn it a little bit
wider like this because any point along
this parabola should be equidistant to
the focus and to this line called the
directrix and you can see the distance
from the vertex to the focus and the
vertex to the directrix is the same
that's what we call the focal distance
or the p value in our equation here
let's get into some examples I'll show
you what I mean so let's say we want to
graph this one x squared equals 16 Y the
first thing we want to notice is that
the X is squared okay so that tells us
going to be opening up or down and P is
positive so we can see it's going to be
opening up so if I draw a graph here the
vertex is at the origin because it
hasn't been shifted there's not an H or
K and the p value is 4 so i'm going to
go up 1 2 3 4
so that's where the focus is right there
because 16 equals 4p I just set those
equal and solve for P and I'm gonna go
down 4 and that gives us the directrix
right there so that's the equation y
equals negative 4
now another little hint okay that makes
graphing these a lot easier is that at
the level of the focus okay see right
here at the level to focus this width is
equal to 4p okay did you catch that so
that means that over here at the level
of focus this is going to be 16 units
wide so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go 8 to the right okay and I'm
gonna go eat to the left okay and so
that gives me an idea about how wide to
draw the parabola okay you see how that
works so this distance from here to here
is 16 it's opening up because this is a
positive P value and it's an x squared
variety okay let's go to the next one so
this one here is a little bit more
challenging you can see this one's been
shifted and you can see it's a Y squared
type which means it's going to be
opening right or left but because this
value is negative it's going to be
opening to the left so let's see if we
can draw a graph of this so where's the
vertex for this parabola can you tell
it's going to be at negative 3 see the
opposite and positive 2 so the one group
of the X is the x coordinate of the
vertex so one group of the why is the
why then they have the opposite sign so
this is going to be left 3 and up 2 so
there's the vertex right there now we
know it's going to be opening to the
left and if I set 12 equal to 4 P that
means P is negative 3 so I'm going to go
1 2 3 okay so there's the focus there's
the vertex and if I go 3 the other
direction okay 1 2 3
there's the directrix okay now remember
at the level 2 focus it's going to be 4
py so it's going to be 12 wide so I'm
going to go up 6 and down 6 from the
focus 1 2 3 4 5 6 so right about there
and 1 2 3 4 5 6 right about there
so that gives me an idea
about how wide to draw the parabola so
again this distance right here is 4 py
12 wide okay so far so good sometimes
I'll ask you for the equation of the
axis of symmetry this line right here
meaning if you fold it over that line
the parabola will match to itself so you
can see that's a horizontal line in this
case it's going to be y equals 2 and
this one here it's going to be x equals
0 okay so here with me so far
okay now the last example I want to show
you is how do you work backwards to find
the equation if they're giving you some
information about the parabola so say
for example the vertex is at 1/2 and the
focus is at 3 2 how do we find the
equation ok well what I like to do is I
like to draw a sketch just so I can
visualize it a little bit so let's do
that
so basically right here we have vertex
is at 1 2 ok I'll just write a letter V
for vertex the focus is at 3 2 so I'm
just gonna put a little F for focus so
what that tells us we know that the
parabola is gonna be opening towards the
focus like you see here's the focus it's
like inside of the parabola in a sense
see like that right ok so this we know
this is going to look something like
this
all right so we know that since its
opening to the right it's a Y squared
variety the vertex is at 1/2 so we're
gonna be using this form right here so
it's going to be Y minus 2 okay
equals X minus 1 ok this is going to be
Y minus 2 squared okay and then now we
just have to find this value right here
okay
the distance from the vertex to the
focus that distance is 2 that's the P
distance the focal distance so 4 times 2
gives us 8 and it's a positive 8 because
it's opening to the right if it is open
to the left would be negative 8